Fester's Quest.
It's just a kidnapping of an entire city by an alien UFO.
Will Fester sit still for this?
Nostalgia! And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe. You know, going by the back of the box, they seem to be aware of the lunacy that is Fester's Quest.
I mean, I was expecting lunacy from Adam's family, but this is just not the kind of lunacy that I expected.
It's just that the back of the box to me just doesn't...
I don't get it.
Does Uncle Fester sit still a lot?
Or like, what is the sit still thing?
Am I missing something really obvious?
I actually don't know too much about Adam's family.
Like, I mean, I imagine I watched some of it as a kid, but I don't know any of the deep lore.
Me neither. I'd love to find out that he's a character that's like, you know, usually in a wheelchair.
And then in this game, he finally gets up out of the wheelchair and walks everywhere.
But I don't think that's true.
I don't know what the sit still line is for.
But the rest of it kind of makes sense because that, you know, it's just a kidnapping, right?
Of an entire city by aliens.
Like, all right, cool. Like, I think they're aware of what they've set out to do.
And, you know, if nothing else, the experience of the start of this game where the story is communicated to you, you don't have to read the back of the box of the manual.
They actually have, before you ever press start, cut scenes that show all this to you.
So that, for me, was enough of a selling point that I was like, all right, I'm ready for weird.
Yeah. And again, I just, I think it's a missed opportunity to make it, like, alien invasion weird because the whole series is sort of based off of this macabre, like, just sort of Victorian horror thing.
But sure, I'm ready for weird.
Yeah. And, you know, we thought Scrooge, Scrooge McDuck was weird last week.
You know, now getting a whole game where you can only ever play as one particular member of the Addams Family and choosing it to be Uncle Fester as just the very first Addams Family video game ever made just feels like a bizarre decision.
I could understand if they're, like, planning a Addams Family video game universe where you'll be able to play, like, each one has their own game and this is just the first in the line with Fester's Quest.
But this is pretty much it as far as where Addams Family games go.
That factoid actually surprises me because usually there's some obscure Atari 2600 game that's happened before these.
So, wow.
I'm amazed we're actually finally seeing the first of something.
Yeah. My question for you guys, which it sounds like you guys also are not, like, big Addams Family fans.
So maybe you won't know the answer either.
But, like, is Uncle Fester, like, normally, like, some badass, like, gunslinging, like, character?
Like, it's just...
I don't know. From not knowing anything about the Addams Family, my guess is this does not represent Uncle Fester in the way most people see him in the show.
I could be totally wrong there.
Is his gun usually depicted as, like, a megaphone?
Yeah. Yeah, I think it's...
It's like a weird horn-looking thing.
It's not really, like, a revolver.
I mean, it's like a cartoon blasted-back rifle thing.
It's like an alien gun.
Oh, okay.
I wasn't thinking alien gun.
I was just thinking, like, maybe a 1700s gun.
Something. Yeah, like one of those, like...
I was thinking, like, a bugle.
He's just got a trumpet.
Well, you could start at a lot of different places when you want to talk about this game.
I did want to just mention that on top of the whole, like, cinematic experience of the cutscene at the top of when the game starts,
there is something really strange about the sudden juxtaposition right after that with the Fester's Quest title screen
looking like something that one of the children of the developers at Sunsoft had just decided to make.
It's all crazy colors.
It's not really, like, a, you know, a design.
It's not themed.
Yeah, it's not themed for a pinata or something, like a party, you know?
Here we have the Addams Family music.
Yeah, we have the Addams Family music playing, though,
and I guess that lets you know that at least they got the intellectual property rights to make this game.
No, they just bought Fester.
But, see, I'm going to just get this theory out of the way right now.
Were we pretty certain this was created as some other game and then they just slapped Addams Family skin on it?
Oh, I mean, that's...
That was my thought the whole time. It almost seems more than likely, but...
Yeah. Because it seems like it was going for this, like, very, like, badass kind of...
Even, like, the music in the regular game just does not sound like it's trying to, you know, invoke Addams Family.
No, you're probably right.
Right. I kind of agree with this baseless assessment.
Yeah, well, good. That's most of my assessments are baseless anyways, so I'm glad I could get something out of it.
And I don't know if, Mike, if you know this, but they did something similar with Doki Doki Panic,
because that's what Super Mario Bros.
2 is. I've heard that urban legend once or twice in my life, but thank you for confirming that they did do that.
No problem. I'd like to just keep you up on that.
Yeah. Now, here's the thing about Fester's Quest, though.
I don't see anything that says that this is a Doki Doki Panic situation.
And keep in mind, Sunsoft made, you know, Blaster Master, which is a, you know, a game that...
It sounds like it's weird that I'm bringing that up, but, like, a lot of the portions of Fester's Quest,
like, certainly not the 3D aspects, but, like, this top-down thing is very similar to Blaster Master's format
of when you get out of the, you know, the vehicle and then start going in the top-down levels.
I feel like this is similar to that in some regards.
So they basically just had an engine and probably acquired a license and said,
eh, well, we already know what we can do, so let's just make that, but with the Addams Family.
Now, how do we do that?
Yeah, that would make sense, too.
So Fester's Quest is a run-and-gun adventure game.
Adventure being kind of nice to the whole idea of, you know, the quest that you go on here.
But basically, as I mentioned, the entire city has been abducted by aliens,
and now only Uncle Fester can traverse through the neighborhood,
try to track down basically the monsters that have somehow found their way onto the land
to reveal pieces to the puzzle that will get him to the alien's UFO ship,
and he'll be able to take them down and free the entire city.
That sounds pretty epic in scale.
I'm sure we all know after playing this game for a little bit that you're mostly being reduced to
exploring the neighborhood, exploring the sewers, and exploring the buildings,
which is, like, the 3D aspect of this.
Rather than talk about what you do in this game,
I want to start with Fester himself here.
You know, this is the character you're going to be playing as throughout the entirety of the game.
He's this balding old man, not something I feel like kids would feel.
You know, it's, like, cool to be Donatello or Leonardo.
It's not cool to be Uncle Fester.
So what does it feel like to control Uncle Fester here?
Feeble Fester, if you will.
I mean, he controls relatively normally,
for the most part, if he hasn't been licked by an enemy,
in which case he feels like a personification of frustration.
But in general, if you have not been licked,
if Fester has not been licked,
he feels normal enough.
He's slow, but, like, it's tight.
Yeah, I agree.
As far as, like, literally the controls of, like,
how he moves and the inputs,
it's perfectly fine.
It doesn't mean that there aren't other problems
with the way the game,
the way that your inputs interact with the environment and stuff,
but as far as actual walking,
it feels great. Yeah, when you shoot,
when you press the shoot button,
he shoots. Yeah.
In a straight line at first.
Yeah. Which is important.
Which is intuitive. Yeah, it's intuitive.
So I called him Feeblefester
because I don't know how you guys felt,
but the version of him
that we start the game off with, right,
the base character,
if this was an RPG,
he would be, like, level negative seven.
He's so powerless at the beginning of this game
compared to the enemies around him.
The very first enemy in the game,
the Goomba of this game, if you will,
is something that takes, like, seven hits to kill.
And for me, I'm just wondering,
why even start the game on that kind of scale?
You know, it doesn't bode well
when a game's primary strategy
at the very beginning
is grinding enemies senselessly
to collect all the power-ups
that you possibly can
to be strong enough
to then make it through the rest of the game.
When the start of the game is grinding,
it's like, imagine if Dragon Warrior started
and the slimes that you fight
right outside the city
are incredibly tough encounters
where it's like, every single time,
it's like, oh, you just made that out
by the skin of your teeth. You gotta go back to the city
and heal now and then go back out there
and fight another one for just two experience points.
That's kind of what it felt like
for me at the beginning of Fester's Quest here.
Well, it doesn't just stop there.
It's like, and we've had games
that start off like really rough
but then after a while
you start to get used to it
or the problem starts to subside
because you've grown into,
you've grown into some power yourself.
But no, this entire game
has enemies that will always
just take forever
for one reason or another.
Yeah, and it gave me,
especially that happening
with that first enemy,
I don't know if the Goomba
of this game that you're talking about, Mike,
is that weird, like,
that weird, like, spiky ball thing
that just literally doesn't move.
But that, first of all,
should not be anything.
It's not an enemy.
It doesn't attack you. You just have to shoot it
to get power-ups
a bunch of times.
But then second of all,
you run into shortly thereafter
one tiny enemy
that moves a little bit.
And because it moves
and you take 40 hits to kill it,
it gives me the immediate
first impression of, like,
the first impression of this game
is the grind that usually
comes much later in a game,
like, this tediousness.
Like, it starts off,
in my opinion, on the wrong foot.
Yeah, I feel like
just make Fester stronger
or the enemies weaker, right?
You don't have to make Fester
this ultimate powerful thing
if you want to build up,
you know, the idea that
over time your gun
will get stronger and you'll acquire this whip.
And don't worry about
the light bulbs. Like, they'll be things
that you find rather than just
hopefully they randomly spawn
from the enemies that you kill.
Instead, they could have
just made the enemies
just weaker altogether
at the start of this game.
You know, I'm not saying
that they should have been one-hit kills,
but it is absurd
how much it takes, especially when
you have to start this game
grinding for
hoping that you get keys
or hoping that you get light bulbs
so that you can progress
throughout this game.
I was even just watching
a Let's Play of this game,
and funny enough,
Let's Plays, for those of you that don't know,
I feel like they are framed perfect
a lot of the times.
Like, there are somebody who's just putting the inputs in
and getting the game to go through.
It's not somebody's, like,
actual playthrough of those games.
You never really see anybody die
in a long play.
I mean, it depends, but yeah, I know what you mean.
Most of the time, it's a perfect run.
Right, in those
World of Long Plays videos,
you know, obviously, like, if it's a person
with a personality,
you know, they'll,
you know what I mean? You know, it's like
the World of Long Plays ones
are just the actual
raw gameplay footage,
and it feels like they're programmed
to do exactly what you'd have to do
to show the full game
from beginning to end. This one had, like,
an extra little slice of comedy
at the start where the Fester goes out there
and immediately dies.
Like, they make a point
to show you that, like,
this game can end
very quickly if you're not paying attention,
and then they show you
the full run without Fester ever
taking another hit
in the game, and I thought
that was a very cheeky
of World of Long Plays
to go and do that.
Start the game
with the game over. And yeah,
that was sort of my experience.
I died pretty quickly,
and then, because I usually,
because I do have the ability to do turbo,
but usually I won't do it,
but then I read in the manual
that they're like, you might want to use
your turbo controller,
and now I think
that this game
was designed around the use of one,
because, like, otherwise,
like, I did just die
immediately because my fingers were getting numb
from the amount of
just, like, over and over
tapping the A button
to, or the B button,
I don't remember what button I was pressing,
to shoot. But so, like,
you do need that,
or you will have
some trouble, more trouble
than you normally would.
Yeah, and it's totally
a valid strategy,
by the way, if you do want
to beat this game, to just grind it out
in the very first part
of the neighborhood. The things that
the enemies drop
don't become any
different later on,
so theoretically, you could walk out
before you ever go
into another building,
you could have
the most powerful gun,
you could have 30 light bulbs
and all that,
like, everything's gonna, you know,
everything could be available to you
right from the beginning of the game,
now you just have to figure out
where to go
and what to do.
I feel like
it's kind of obvious
based on the path
that they developed for the neighborhood.
I'm not, I question
the HOA society
that the Addams family
participates in
because the layout of the neighborhood
is very strange
and it does lead
in like a sort of maze
that pushes you
in the directions
that the game wants you to go in,
but for the most part,
figuring out what to do
and where to go
wasn't really like a,
I don't know, it didn't feel
like an adventure.
That was kind of what I was saying earlier
when I was describing this
as a running gun adventure game.
The adventure part
I certainly get on,
you know, because you're going on a quest,
but it's mostly just
laid out in front of you.
There aren't really like any,
I mean, it feels relatively open.
Like the roads are wide.
There are like, not alternate pathways,
but there are many dead ends
that could make it
feel more open.
So I get that.
It wasn't obvious to me.
Huh. Okay.
I guess I didn't feel
like, I'm not saying like, oh,
you didn't get it. I guess what I mean
is like, it's not a,
it's not the open style game
that we're used to where like every house,
right, is like, oh, well,
which one do I want to go into?
Like, which one do I want
to get information from?
It's like, you're going in the path
and it's like, all right, this is the house
that's in front of me. So I have the key,
I'll use it and then I'll talk to Wednesday
or, you know,
somebody else from the Addams family
because apparently they live in
other people's houses now.
They don't, they don't live
at the Addams family residence.
They, they've moved
to everybody else's houses,
but there's no,
there's no actual like,
you know, layout of the neighborhood
that makes it all
that interesting. You're, you're connected by sewers
that you get it,
that you go into and then they just
transport you to new areas
of the same neighborhood.
It's not like something
unlocks later.
I mean, I guess also just
in terms of level design,
if it was just a regular,
regularly designed roadway
where there, you could just go
to anyone's house by walking down the street,
it would be a little,
a little boring,
maybe. Well, yeah,
I mean, I think that the,
the layout is, this is all about the,
you know, the game design
and, you know,
the reason why cities
based on real cities
and video games are never actually laid out
like the real cities,
except for like in Spider-Man.
But, but,
yeah, I mean, I, I see,
I get what you're saying.
Like, it's not like what we're, it's not like an RPG
kind of thing
that we're used to where it was something like,
even with something like
Vaxanadu, where,
you know, it's not like quite that open
in that sense,
but it didn't feel to me
like, like it was totally on rails
either, you know, it felt like,
you know, it felt like there was
some, some decent exploration to do.
And I think in that exploration,
I will say, I think that the presentation
of this game aesthetically
is, is really,
really good too.
So that kind of made it a little more palatable
to, to kind of explore around.
Yeah, I agree.
So then let's talk about
maybe, you know,
what we thought,
not necessarily what a strategy guide
would want you to do, but just figuring out
like the lay of the land
and what you guys wanted to do
to beat the game and such.
Not that we had to beat the game.
What, what was the first steps
that you did? Did you grind at the beginning
to try to get more powerful?
Did you, did you not know
how to get in the buildings
because you need keys for those?
Did you go into the sewer
in the dark? Let's hear about it.
I, I did, um,
basically all those things.
Uh, well,
not, I did not do the grinding
because I did not know
I had to grind.
Uh, I knew that there were things
that were dropped and I could collect them,
but grinding is probably
the last thing ever
on my mind
in any game. Uh,
so I, I would never choose
to do that. Um,
but, uh,
yes, I did walk through
the sewer in the dark
because I did not know
how to use items.
I didn't realize that,
like, you kind of just select
something in the sub menu
and then you use a button
in the actual,
like, overworld to use it
until I got to,
um, the first,
like, 3D maze building.
And I think I got,
like, a bug because the first time
I tried to do that,
I used the key
and it, like, threw me to
the start screen.
Whoa. And,
like, was I not supposed
to do that?
Was I, did I,
like, did I think that I
pressed the reset button?
And that, that did not,
that did not make me feel good.
Um, but then,
like, you know, what I did,
maybe I did something differently or I,
uh, or,
or the game did not bug out
and I actually was able
to get into it. But,
yes, I walked through the,
the sewer in the dark
and just sort of, like,
shot at shadows,
which was very difficult
because I had a gun
that shot in loop-de-loops
that apparently,
if you run into a wall,
it stops. I'm sure we'll get into
that later. Um,
it was, it was bizarre,
uh, to say the least.
Yeah, I, I did a lot of
the same things too.
I mean, I kind of just explored
at first just to see
what was going on and, and once I figured out,
like, how the grinding worked,
I did grind a little bit
and I'll say the,
the act of grinding
itself in this game
is not as bad
as a lot of other games
just because it's,
it's just, so many of these enemies
drop these, these pickups
and you, you pick up one item
and you're like, you're basically,
you've, you've basically leveled up.
You know, your, your gun is,
has leveled up. Your whip has leveled up.
Um, so it's not like,
it doesn't take a ton
of grinding. I'll say that I don't really,
I don't really understand
necessarily the logic
of which weapons,
like, the order of which
the weapons go. Like,
supposedly this one's
better than that one, but sometimes they're like,
sometimes it almost feels
like a disadvantage to get the next weapon.
the patterns. Yeah,
yeah, because what it is is like,
like, they, they get more powerful.
It seems like each,
each shot gets more powerful,
but yeah, they, they shoot and they fire
in different patterns and in some of those patterns,
you, they, it means that you can't aim
directly in front of you
because like the, the thing goes in like a squiggle
and it'll go right around
what you're shooting at and you gotta like,
it's, it's like counterintuitive
in that sense, so like, that's weird.
But yeah, grinding was a big thing
that I started doing,
trying to gather a bunch of weapons
and then really, like I,
I'll admit, like I never really had
like an overall goal,
like this is what I have to do next.
It was always just like,
wander. Oh,
I got this key, I'll,
I'll try this thing,
now I can go in here and I have a light bulb,
so let's see what's over here
and I just kept going. you know,
I found a couple of,
I found one thing of extra health,
like, you know, I got some,
I got some items
from different members
of the Addams family
and stuff, but I was,
I'll admit that I was
a little aimless on my,
on my personal quest.
description there, Sean,
because that, that is the game
and it's like most pure
when you don't know
how, um,
formulaic it is
of just like, get the keys
that hopefully
the enemies drop
whenever you see a house,
use the key to unlock
to get an Addams family member
to give you some important item
that you'll need later
or, or not necessarily
too important, but just helpful items.
And then, you know,
go to the sewer and that just takes you
to the next area. If you are like,
you playing this game
with a strategy guide,
I could find that,
like, reducing the amount of time
that you actually do wind up playing the game
because of it
just revealing stuff to you.
I do feel like,
at the very least,
Fester is on a quest,
which is better
than what Castle Quest
was proposing.
No castle went on a quest
in that game.
Fester does feel like
he is on a mission.
Why he was chosen for it,
I don't know. Why the rest of the Addams family
can't participate, but can give him items.
Maybe they're watching
everybody else's house
while the aliens
are running them up.
Oh, they're house-sitting. Yeah, they're house-sitting
for everybody who's been kidnapped,
I thought they were very antisocial,
but I guess, like, it all makes sense.
Yeah, and I guess,
like, you know,
at the end of the day, does it matter
who you're playing as
when it doesn't feel,
like, unique to that character
either? Like, this gun thing
doesn't feel exclusive
to Uncle Fester.
I don't know if that's true or not,
but it just doesn't feel,
like, I'm really playing
his uncle, Fester,
you know? Like,
if you gave Wednesday
the gun, it'd be the same thing,
right, to me? Going back to the gun thing
for a minute, because I know
there's two things we want to talk about.
Gun level 1
all the way up to gun level 8,
it is a little confusing,
Joe, that they just, like,
choose different kinds
of attack powers
that, or sprays,
rather, that aren't particularly
helpful, but you can tell
that they're doing more damage,
then you have to change to that,
and it is kind of
revealing that the final gun level 8
is just a straight line,
so it feels like
they kind of revealed that they knew
that that was the best thing to do,
just to have a gun that shoots in a straight line,
like, if the final form
was some kind of,
you know, three-way spray,
then maybe it'd be like,
oh, this is great, and also covers
a lot of advantages,
but it doesn't do that here.
However, both of you have mentioned
something that is a big
problem with the game,
and that is because
whether you're
in the neighborhood or in the sewers,
you're going to want
to use your gun,
and you're going to be
in somewhat, most of the time,
tight corners, and any wall
in this game
immediately stops
your bullets
from progressing any further
from where they are,
and so if you're,
you know, running into a hedge
or you're running, you know,
up against these sewer walls,
when you shoot
these curved weapons,
these ones that purposefully rotate
and such, it makes them
so much less powerful
because they,
they arc in a way
that immediately just disintegrates them
that it's not helpful
to the player at all
and makes you want
just only the weapons
that shoot in a straight line.
Yeah, it's,
it's a cardinal sin
and the fact that
like 80% of the time
that you try to shoot a gun,
depending on what
level your gun is at,
you cannot use it.
It, it, it's,
it's beyond the pale.
Yeah. And to,
to really paint the picture
for anyone who hasn't played the game,
you know, imagine having a gun
that fires out and it fires at like
an S formation
over and over, you know,
just wiggles that way
towards, you know,
towards its destination. But now imagine
you're walking parallel to a wall.
So you just,
you fire the gun
and your bullet just immediately
goes diagonally
directly into the wall
that's next to you. That's what happens
for like half of this game.
Anytime you're, you're in a hallway,
which is like half of the game
or like near a,
a wall,
and there's something in front of you,
you almost, you can't hit it
until it gets between you
and that wall basically
because you, you just fire
in the weirdest,
most unorthodox,
unhelpful direction.
It's like the, it's like the actual
rifle part of your gun
is curved like in a cartoon
and only shoots
to the side of you.
It's, it's a mess.
Yeah. And like, that's not the only,
you know, like that goes away
if you get more power-ups,
but like the other ones,
well, I don't think any of them
are as bad as that.
They're also sometimes
not like the best.
Yeah. And oddly enough,
in my, you know,
just short research
for this game,
it turns out that the whole,
like when you shoot,
it, you know,
hits a wall and then it just like,
that's it. That's the end of the bullet.
That's not true
for the European release
of this game. And that's just a bug
in the North American
version of this game.
Now we are playing
every game released in North America.
So this is absolutely
true for us, but it's weird to think
that, you know,
I'm not saying it makes the whole game
so much better or anything,
right? But it's weird to think
that, you know,
just across the pond,
these guys wouldn't
understand what we were
talking about right now
with the bullets
because they wouldn't
have ever experienced that because they would
have fixed the bug
in it,
in the other market. You know,
it's like, why not just,
how do you miss
something like that?
Something so large
like that if it was unintended?
Yeah. And then to not
like realize
during play testing
that this is happening
and that maybe
this wasn't intended.
Like it makes me feel
like it was intended
and then they were just
like, we're going to put them
into these little tiny areas
just so that they're
going to get really angry at the game
and that that was
intentional. And then like,
oh, wow, people didn't really
like the way that
our guns flew into the wall
immediately. So I guess we
should change that.
Yeah. Well,
you know, and it flying
into the wall, I don't think was
the only thing that made it feel
like it was
an accident
though, because the other,
it seems like
the point of this
of this particular
shot is to like
cover more ground.
So it's like, oh, there's a whole
cluster of enemies coming at you
so you can like, you might hit a bunch
of them or whatever. But it all,
the bullet also stops
when it hits one enemy.
So even if you do
hit one enemy, it's,
you still would have been better off
with just a straight shot because the
whole point of a, in any other game,
the whole point of a, a firearm that,
that spreads out
like that, I mean, is,
well, I guess one is that
maybe you just don't have to be as accurate,
but two, that you can hit
more things at once.
And this doesn't, this still prevents
you from doing that. So the top down
portion of the game
is where you go
through the neighborhood and the sewers,
but there is a 3D,
you know,
maze, dungeon crawl style
aspect to this game
as well, where you don't see
fester. It's a first person
kind of view. It's very similar
to other first person
views that we've seen
on the NES where they're not able
to give too much detail.
They're really just able
to show us the walls.
And I feel like maybe in this one
they added like some kind of ceiling light
fixtures, even though they're not
lit up or anything.
There's like these little
like circle things above
and I always thought like,
why aren't those turned on?
Or are they? And that's why we can see,
I don't know, forget it.
The, the point is that
in this,
you know, in this navigation
of just looking at walls
and the only difference
really being some walls are
completely gray,
some walls are like
gray and another color
below them to add like some
definition or leading
lines to them.
how did that aspect
of discovery go down
for you guys? Are those,
are those short enough
that it didn't become too big of an issue?
Is this just the kind of thing that you just
try to brute force
your way through so that you just like
find the door at the other end?
I like that both of your
example answers here,
neither of them
were positive. Just like,
is this either something
that like you hate
or that you just sort of dealt with?
And it's true
because like the,
in any situation
where there's a 3D
part to the game,
like in the NES games
that we played so far,
it, it's,
it's not great. Like the,
I think the only thing
that, um,
in, in these games
is selling it to people
is that it's a,
it's a novelty. And,
and now that we sort
of know what, what can be done
even with a little
bit more detail,
um, like it,
it's just like,
why not have anything
to do in these
other than to navigate
the maze, um,
without any of that,
it, it just becomes
more tedious.
Uh, if there were,
if there were enemies to do stuff with
and, and the, maybe the,
the combat
wasn't quite as
shoot into the wall
as it is in the top
down, I could sort of
justify them being
here, but because like,
there's literally no detail on any of the
walls, just some stuff,
some different colors
to tell you, like,
uh, you're looking straight
at the wall. Yes,
that's correct. Um,
it, it just sort of
took up time and that's all I
saw this as. Yeah.
I, I mean, I agree that
when we see this
in a game, it's generally not
great on the NES.
Um, I'll say that as far
as, I,
I think as, as far as other
games that we've seen do this,
this did a better
job of like,
not making me like,
immediately lose my
bearings. I don't know if it's
because it, it populates much
faster than other
games. I mean, I know we had one
game, I can't remember what it was,
where we had like a compass and that
was very helpful. In this game,
there is no compass, but I never felt
like I got like super like,
oh, okay, everything looks
the same. So I have no
idea where I am.
Um, that didn't happen
to me, which is weird
because it is true
that everything looks the same.
It felt like,
and I, I,
maybe I'm misremembering the
other games, but it felt like
each screen
populated much faster.
And the problem
that I was having is that the,
the walls are all
bright white. And in order for
the next screen to populate,
populate, it has to blink
to black and then
back to white real
quick, which just leads me,
I mean, I don't know if it bothered anyone else,
but it was just, it's just the whole
time you're playing through these
prices, just flashing
lights in your face.
Like, like it's like
seizure inducing.
Yeah. And that's also part
of like, they're actually doing
the opposite of
what I need
because I did get
kind of lost in these.
It's doing the opposite of what
I would need to
make it not that
like instead of
flashing to black
and then back to
the new direction
that you're facing, this just needs
one little
interstitial frame
where it shows
like a 45 degree
angle of like
when you're turning. So it needs
that so that
I can at least like still have
a point of reference to where I was
five seconds ago.
And none of these
games have that yet,
like all these 3D ones.
Um, so until
they figure that
out, maybe it's not
possible. I don't know.
But until they figure that out,
I'm going to hate every single one
of these. Yeah.
And I don't know if I can't
remember again, I just obviously
can't remember any other ones
clearly enough,
but I don't know if it's like a
technical limitation,
but, but does it have
to cut to black
before it goes to the next
screen in these? Like,
can't it just go to the next
screen? Well,
that was my question,
Joe. Yeah, I agree.
Yeah, it's probably
a rendering issue,
you know, where you have to,
um, figure,
you know, like, that isn't
an easy thing for
them to program, obviously,
if it's like this bare
bones that we're getting, you know,
if we're getting like super stylized
top-down stuff, and then
all of a sudden it's like,
I hope you like walls,
like, that's the best we can give
you right here, you know, like,
hope you can understand what
we're going for. I do wonder
about that, but we've, we have never
had, if it was
like faster to react
or whatever, but we've
never had a game that showed any
kind of turning, or any
kind of like, here's where
you were, you know,
like, context for
where you were previously,
you have to keep the
context in
mind based on the
buttons you pressed on
the D-pad, and I know
that sounds strange,
right, it's like, well, that's what
it's supposed to do, right,
Mike? It's like, I don't know,
cameras are supposed to be
a little better to helping
the brain fill in the
pieces, and that's
what I'm missing, and that's
what helps with getting
lost in here,
is that it's not
like how you would
explore a
maze, that's the problem with
all these early dungeon
crawlers, is that it's
not how we think of
our eyes
in real life, so when it
doesn't work that way, it's like the
game makes
it so much stranger to
traverse, it feels very
foreign. That's a
great, that's another
great phrase, I already
forgot what the words were,
but it was like, that's why I
say them so fast. It's not
how we make our eyes.
It's not what we expect our
eyes to feel like.
I usually close my
eyes during
each step, and then I
open my eyes real
quick just to see where
I am, and then I close them again for
the next step. To avoid
motion. little snapshots.
Have I got a video game for
you? Yeah. I also like in
the manual that it has in the
how to play section,
the first thing they want you
to know is that there's three types of
views for the
top-down levels,
and they won't show
you one of them, which I think
is funny. They'll list
them out, but then it's
just like, I know they
didn't mean it like this, but the way
that it's put
is just there
is also a 3D
hallway view. It feels like
they're revealing that as some
kind of secret or little thing
that they've built into the
game, but it winds
up becoming one of the most annoying
parts of the game. So it's like,
maybe explain a
little more. How do we
act in a 3D
hallway, assuming I've
never seen one before,
Sunsoft? Like, maybe,
you know, if this is
brand new technology that's
pretty cool and is
simulating 3D,
there should be like a half a
page in the manual for that
kind of thing. I mean,
yeah. I guess we've
seen it enough times that,
and no, it's only been a
handful of times, but it's not
entirely new,
so maybe they were just like,
you get it, you live in 3D,
you've gone down hallways,
this is what it's like.
But, yeah, I don't know.
Yeah, well, on that note,
I guess I'm glad
that they didn't make it any more
complicated than
just walking
through these halls to find
what I can only
describe as
just some of the
most horrific bosses I've ever
seen on the NES,
and we've seen some colorful
stuff, but these guys,
they're pretty scary-looking
bosses for a game
that otherwise has, like,
cute, cartoony enemies
and characters
that we know and love.
These bosses
definitely never
appeared in the
Addams Family TV
show. Some of them
look like they're straight from hell,
like they came from doom,
which I make that
reference, obviously, because of the
3D hallways, but to then switch
to, like, this completely
black screen
where it's just
you and the
devil, and you have to
just shoot them
from a distance. Don't even try
getting up close to them,
but you have to, like,
shoot at them in,
I guess you could
say it's, like, a shmup at that
point, right? Like,
you're dodging their attacks
and you're shooting yours.
Yeah, it even looks like you're
in space because you're
just on a black background.
They get rid of any context
to where you are, which is,
on one hand, kind of,
like, lackluster,
but on the other hand, actually kind
of, like, feels kind
of epic.
I don't know if I was just
filling that in, but.
these enemy,
these boss designs
are so detailed.
I think maybe they did that
just because of that,
like, the bosses
are, they have so much
going on with animation and
stuff that they did,
they should, they couldn't
have a background or they'd be,
like, flickering or something.
But I also do
think that it adds to it in
terms of a, like,
thematic way,
like, the, like,
at the end of Final Fantasy 7
where it's just you and Sephiroth
on a black background and
it's sort of like, I know it's not
exactly what they were going for,
but it kind of feels that way.
Yeah, yeah, which,
like, you know, I stand by
that this game is aesthetically
very nicely designed.
Outside of the hallways. Outside of the,
yes, outside of the 3D
hallways, thank you. You know,
I'm just thinking about one boss
in particular, and I know
we're calling them bosses, but they are,
like, they are bosses
for all of the Yeah, they're bosses.
The, um,
the, like,
worm, it has,
like, a worm-like head,
it has one
eye, it's,
it's wearing,
like, a jumpsuit
or a tracksuit,
it's a riddle, and it has a,
and it has a gun
pointed directly
at you, like,
just always, always pointed
at you. Something about
that creature,
which I guess is, like, half chicken,
half worm the chicken one,
worm or something, yeah,
I don't know, that thing
is very spooky.
This is just, like,
a funny, weird thing
in this, in this game,
though, when you consider
Uncle Fester.
It reminds me of
Super Mario RPG
on the Super Nintendo,
how, like, that whole game,
aesthetically, everything fits,
everything works, it's this cute,
like, claymation style
approach to the design,
but there's a secret
boss that can only
be described as, like,
a Final Fantasy style
god-like character,
and then you have
Mario just jumping
on his head, you know,
like, as how he deals damage,
and it's, like,
kind of the same thing with Fester here,
like, I don't know, these guys belong
in Contra, not in Uncle Fester's
quest. No,
that was the standout
for me as well, was the hunched over
chicken gun wielder,
I think that that,
that's gonna be, like,
a timeless enemy
design for me,
and I probably will never play this game
again, so. Yeah,
there's another one that is,
like, this dinosaur one,
I think it's after the chicken thing,
and he's got, like, a long,
he's got, like, a long neck,
but, like, no head,
like, his neck just, like,
culminates in an eyeball,
and, like, oh, yeah, it's,
like, very, yeah,
like, they put a lot of
interesting and
unsettling design into this,
just, surprising,
but I think that one stood out to me
even more so than the chicken.
They didn't need the UFO thing
to, to have these enemy designs in there,
like, it's, again, it's already,
like, sort of a comedy horror series,
and, speaking of that,
like, there's really not much comedy in this game,
aside from the idea of buying hot dogs,
uh, during an alien invasion,
and maybe the,
uh, the noose,
uh, the,
the noose item,
like, uh,
before destroying all the enemies on the screen,
like, that guy just shows up and just says,
you rang, and,
this is no, it's not very Adam's family in either way,
I, I'm getting off topic here,
but. No, you're actually on topic,
because I think,
the next thing I was gonna talk about anyway,
was meeting the rest of the family,
it, it's true, that,
meeting the family is,
like, the relief point in this game,
where you almost have to, like, center yourself and realize,
like, oh yeah, this is an Adam's family game,
like, that's what I'm doing here,
like, uh, I'm not,
I'm not trying to take down demons from hell,
I'm not trying to,
uh, you know,
I am trying to rescue,
uh, the entire city from a bunch of aliens,
but, nevertheless,
it's nice to meet the rest of the Adam's family,
but they're just included in such an uninteresting way,
that I feel like there,
there could have been a lot more to their inclusion,
not, we don't need cut scenes,
we don't need, um,
we don't need them to become,
like, playable characters as well or anything,
but their inclusion in,
like, either, after a boss fight or something,
like, revealing, like,
a clue on what to do next,
obviously, like, the game's not complicated enough to require clues or something,
but if they made it that way,
it could have been, I feel like the only way of seeing them,
by entering the house,
and, like, just being, uh,
it's, it's like a piece of paper that tells you what they've given you,
and, and then you're just on your merry way again,
they, they could have done a little more than that,
because this is an Adam's family game,
even if it's just supposed to be about Fester,
and, I,
I don't feel like there's enough branding here,
other than the theme song,
uh, from the show,
and the fact that they included the other characters in the game.
Yeah, well, those other characters,
you know, and going to those houses and giving those items,
are, that's exactly,
those are the exact moments where I was like,
oh, this was,
this might not have been intended to be an Adam's family game,
like, that's what made me think that,
because it feels so shoehorned in,
I mean, it's not even, like, the same style,
like you said, it's just this, it's just this image of them comes up full screen,
just this, like, image of,
like, this giant pixel art of that character comes up,
and says, like, they don't even have dialogue,
it just says, this person gave you this,
it just feels like they were like,
oh, yeah, this is somewhere we can make it Adam's family related,
you don't remember that episode,
you don't remember that episode of,
of Adam's family,
where Wednesday gives somebody vice grips,
yeah, is, is there a narrator in Adam's family that just narrates what everybody does,
and we just see images of them,
Wednesday's vice grips,
what do the vice grips do again,
they like make you, they make you fast again,
after you get, I think it's like a permanent status,
when you get stung by a,
by, by like a,
a bug enemy,
or get licked by the frog people,
that you are just,
half, half speed,
and it makes the game,
again, unplayable,
so what's the implication there,
like, that the vice grip,
like, do you, I don't know what that means,
like, yeah, I don't understand,
have the, the,
the next time I get a bug bite,
I will, yeah,
apply a vice grip to my finger,
or whatever, and see what happens,
yeah, like, I wanted to say,
like, the bug makes your muscles tense up,
and the vice grip wouldn't loosen them,
it would make them even tighter,
so like, I don't know, trying to come up with some story,
to, to bail,
the Adam's family,
Fester's quest, out of this pickle,
they've gotten themselves into,
well, they also just ran out of characters,
in general, and wind up using,
thing, three times,
uh, you went into,
the thing, so thing is the hand,
right, yes,
now, who's the long haired dude,
like, the, the thing that's just hair,
oh, I thought that was thing,
yeah, maybe that is thing,
I always thought thing was the hand,
I mean, maybe it is,
and I think it seems to be,
by the way that the game,
just describes it,
but I always thought that,
the hair thing was the thing,
uh, that's cousin it,
oh, cousin it,
all right, yeah, people are probably shouting at the podcast,
right now, like, you idiot,
he has an IQ of 320,
so surely he would have remembered himself,
and is often attired in bowler hat,
and round sunglasses,
absolutely, I,
I didn't make a grammatical mistake,
Wikipedia did, it says,
often attired in bowler hat,
should be a bowler hat,
it's not a Mike-ism,
that's a Wikipedia-ism,
who wrote the Wikipedia page though,
that was Mike- I did,
yeah, okay,
you know, I don't like to go backwards in segments,
but there was a thought I had,
regarding those 3D mazes,
and why they had to do,
the black flash,
that might have, maybe giving them just the benefit of the doubt here,
and, uh, saying like,
oh, maybe it isn't a rendering thing,
but it was the only way,
because of the way that they themselves,
designed the game,
it was the only way to portray,
movement, in the straight line sections,
not necessarily in the turns,
but in, the set,
in the moments where you're going down hallways,
because, all of the wall,
is exactly the same,
that, that would be the only way,
to show that you had,
moved forward, is to,
okay, yeah, tell me why I'm wrong.
I mean, not why you're wrong,
they may have thought that,
but in, in five seconds,
I can think of a, uh,
of a fix for that,
and that is just like,
you know, those little lights,
that are on the ceiling,
just have those alternate,
problem solved, but,
right, I think, I think you're right,
that maybe that's what they were doing.
Yeah, but you came up with a better solution,
while I was telling you the problem.
You should have worked on sun salt.
You're right, I should have.
So, you're probably gonna die,
at some point in this game,
or in life, uh,
I feel like everybody just needs to hear that.
Yeah. But in,
in Fester's Quest,
you only get one life,
but you have infinite continues.
Yet, the continue feature,
works in a very strange way,
where, even if you do make it all the way to the UFO ship,
if you die there,
when you go to continue,
you start back at the beginning of the game.
And, I,
it's like, oh,
wait a minute, I lost all my progress?
No, you didn't lose all your progress,
but, when you were,
you know, on your way throughout,
throughout this quest, whenever you beat a boss,
that was how you replenished
all of your consumable items,
and, you know,
like, whatever else, right? Like,
at the end, they would boost your health again,
and what have you. So,
that, those bosses are gone now.
that was the way to,
to kind of, like,
you know, restore some,
some sense of,
like, you know, health and all that throughout the game.
Here, now you just have to try to run through the gauntlet again,
of making it all the way back to the UFO ship,
without dying and being transported back to the beginning,
yet again.
So,
you are at,
like, a disadvantage,
depending on where you die in this game,
and how far along you die into this game.
Is this a roguelike?
In a weird,
weird sense, still no.
If they would have included the bosses back.
No, I know. Which would be weird.
Also, it's not randomized.
Right, right, you know, it's like,
but it would be funny, if,
like, the bosses also came back to life,
because then you do have to wonder,
well, what progress did I make?
If they put me back at the beginning of the game,
you've got a really nice whip now,
yeah. I just thought that was a weird choice for dying.
They could have at least remembered,
what part of the sewers you had most recently come out of,
or which house you had exited,
right? You haven't, you haven't shut off the console,
right? Because once you do that,
then you do lose all progress.
I would say so. So,
it knows some,
it knows something about what you've done,
and where you've been,
so why is the respawn point the very beginning?
For challenge, Mike.
Or they could have just included a password system,
right? And a password system that was mediocre at best,
too. It didn't even have to, like,
remember how many keys you have,
and everything, although that would probably lead to,
no, it wouldn't lead to any kind of soft locking,
because nothing is missable.
So, they could have easily designed a password system for this,
and they chose not to do that either.
So, really,
Fester's Quest is a,
you know, a game best played with save states,
but really, if you were playing back then,
it's a one sitting game.
I suppose so,
yeah. I guess,
like, one, one other,
like, bright spot in this game is,
uh, is the soundtrack.
Uh, there, there isn't really too many tracks,
but the ones that do exist are,
are pretty, are pretty jamming,
I would say. And,
and Joe, maybe,
maybe I'm crazy,
but, for some reason,
like, the, the song that plays most of the time,
like, on the overworld,
it reminded me very much of,
like, the flashback sequence battle music,
uh, like,
when you're playing as, like,
Laguna in Final Fantasy VIII.
And I know that might sound crazy.
Yes, I hear it.
I'm listening to it right now.
The Man with the Machine Gun by Nobuo Urimatsu.
Exactly. I hear it.
And, and that just also speaks to how this does not feel like,
like, it has anything to do with Adam's Family.
It's just a really upbeat,
awesome battle track.
Um, but,
yeah, music's pretty good.
Yeah, I liked the music a lot.
It was, like you said, it was jamming.
It felt, it felt intense and,
and, and exciting.
And do you know what it made me think every time I heard a new track?
What? It made me think that this game was not originally intended to be an Adam's Family game.
Exactly. Which might not be true,
but I just want,
I just, I just want to know because I,
it, it just,
nothing about it,
uh, reminds me of The Adam's Family,
a show that I never watched.
I don't know why I'm dying on this hill.
I have no idea. No,
I agree. Nothing else about it.
A show that you never watched is a funny point though,
because we also,
no, but we never participated in DuckTales,
but like, it leaks into your life in little ways and you have expectations.
We did think it was weird that you played as Scrooge McDuck instead of Huey,
Dewey, and Louie, but we didn't like refute it at the end of the day.
We're like, oh, that's fine. He's a character in the show.
Like we knew enough, you know,
here with The Adam's Family,
I'm so angry that Fester's the character.
I just, I,
it's the marketing side of me that that's really upset.
I, the fact that they chose Fester as the most relatable thing to their age,
six to 11 demographic that they were hitting on the NES at that time.
And this is a 1989 and Adam's Family's what?
Like the sixties? Oh yeah.
I don't even care.
Yeah. I don't understand that either.
The movie isn't like it,
you know, maybe it was like announced that they were going to make one,
but that's not till 1991.
I think maybe this triggered the movie.
Maybe they were trying to capitalize on the success of Fester's quest on the NES.
It sold so well.
Yeah. On the sequels and spinoff side,
we have a few games here to talk about.
First is Adam's Family.
They got the memo.
They said, no more Fester.
Let's make the whole family have their own game.
And it is a 1992 platformer on the Super Nintendo and the Genesis that is based on the 1991 movie.
So all the characters look like the updated version of the Adam's Family that most people are probably familiar with and not the original TV show.
After that,
though, we get back to the NES.
Can you believe that? Finally,
a sequels and spinoffs that has a game on a Super Nintendo.
And then they're like, well,
you know what though? That one's too advanced.
We can't make that one on the NES,
but let's make the next one.
The Adam's Family Puglies Scavenger Hunt.
Now, see, you could see why they said that that's great for the NES,
because it's a game where you just play as presumably based on the title,
one character from the Adam's Family.
They couldn't handle having all of the family at once on the NES.
So, at least it's age appropriate.
Right. We will play that game in 1993,
which has already happened,
but when we get to 1993 on the show,
we will play the Adam's Family Puglies Scavenger Hunt.
And it is not based on the movie.
It is not based on the original TV show.
It's based on the second animated series.
Oh, okay.
Which has also already happened.
Yeah, all of it's all happened.
Whoa. Huh.
Adam's Family Values
is a 1995 Super Nintendo Genesis action RPG
based on the film of the same name,
the sequel to Adam's Family,
Adam's Family Values.
How do you say that?
Adam's Family Values?
I'd say Adam's Family Values.
Yeah. I like that.
But you kind of want to just say Adam's Family,
colon, values.
No, no, because the play,
the play on the title,
the play on the words is the fact that you say it that way.
Oh, yeah, no, of course,
but I'm saying like, you also,
you know, your brain wants to say the Adam's Family.
No, your brain. The Adam's Family,
like, you know, you don't say like,
the Adam's Family Values.
Yeah, but you, that's just your brain.
Okay, great.
It's just me. In fact,
if it wasn't me, write it on Twitter.
The new Adam's Family series is an adventure video game released for the Game Boy Color in 2001 based on the TV series.
How many TV series did they make in the 90s about the Adam's Family?
So, uh, the new Adam's Family series apparently was the TV series as well.
So then they said that's a,
that's a Game Boy game if I've ever seen one.
So it came on the Game Boy Color.
You control both Pugsley and Wednesday and navigate the house,
collect items, solve puzzles.
Sounds like I'm reading the back of a box and not really anything informative to anybody.
So, uh,
sorry about that. But just,
I'm amazed that in the sequels and spin-offs section,
which takes place entirely in the 90s,
I've managed to list four different series of the Adam's Family after this game was made based on only something from the 60s.
So Fester's Quest really brought,
uh, the Adam's Family back to life long before the movie ever did.
I want to say that that's just a,
uh, a coinkydink,
uh, and that the movie,
the movie really did do it.
The movie was so good that it brought about a second Adam's Family renaissance of the 90s that somehow we all,
missed, even though we're,
we are otherwise pretty good with 90s culture.
Um, but,
I mean, it's just another thing that I'm,
we'll never truly understand.
You know what would really put Adam's Family back on the map?
An expanded universe?
An open world game?
No, making it an essential game on the Essential Games list.
All right, Sean,
the fate of the Adam's Family cinematic universe is on your shoulders.
Uh, yeah,
there's, maybe,
maybe my opinion of this game would be forever altered by,
uh, a patch,
like the NES patch,
uh, to make it so that projectiles don't collide with walls,
but I don't think that's going to be enough.
Um, I think,
uh, there's, there's too much weird stuff going on here,
um, that tell me that this is,
again, more just an oddity,
uh, with really good music.
Because, aside from that,
the game is not essential.
I, I mean, I keep talking,
I kept talking about the presentation.
I think that it's,
it does a very good job,
but, uh, like the sprite work and the,
just the art in general is great.
And it looks, it looks advanced and the music is great.
And I think really a lot about this game is essential,
except for the fact that it's no fun at all.
Like, like,
like everything else is like,
when I first looked at this game,
I was like, I bet this is,
I bet I'm going to love this game.
Like, this looks awesome.
It's not awesome.
It, I, I really kind of don't like it at all,
which is just, I guess the,
to, it goes to show you don't judge a book by,
it's cover. It's not essential.
Um, I would say that even,
I mean, definitely,
even if they fixed the projectiles hitting the walls,
I would not vote this essential because I think there's just too many other things that are just lackluster or,
or even just not fun.
And even if they fixed,
Oh, okay. Thank you.
I didn't know you were over.
Now, you know, now I do know.
I'm also done. Okay.
Oh, Sean, you're done. Yeah,
I'm done. Okay.
I thought I was interrupting you.
This is my interrupting voice.
even if they fixed the gun bug for the North American release,
even if they remove the whole 3d maze thing that is never interesting in these games,
even if they,
you know, even if Joe's right,
and this isn't an Adams family game,
right? If I remove all Adams family IP from it,
that would actually make the game even less good to be honest.
So, you know, at this point,
I guess what I'm trying to say is that you can fix all those things.
And I'd still not be convinced that this belongs on the essential games list for,
for so many reasons.
And we talked about them on the show,
but I think this isn't also like,
this isn't one of those like worst NES games of all time either,
which is a list that I've seen Fester's quest on,
but I've also seen games like Friday the 13th on there.
And I thought that game was pretty cool too.
Like it turns out the actual worst games on the NES are just really boring games that nobody speaks about.
Like we, we played them and we can't even remember them anymore.
Fester's quest, not necessarily a game.
I'm going to be like telling people like,
Oh, well, thank goodness you didn't play Fester's quest.
Like it's,
it's fine. If you played it,
no harm, no foul, right?
You probably, you probably,
there's probably a lot of kids who had nostalgia for this.
Uh, you know, as we're recording this episode now saying like,
Hey, I, this was the game I owned.
I played the shit out of this all the time because it was really long and I was always dying and I couldn't finish it in one sitting.
And I didn't understand why I was playing his uncle Fester.
So there's always a reason for these things and what have you.
But at the end of the day,
it's not going to go on the essential games list for,
uh, for obvious reasons that we've all mentioned.
Now, if you do want to play essential games,
you should know that Sunsoft did make Master Blaster,
which is an essential game.
Blaster Master. Math Blaster is a game on the computers,
but I know I didn't say that either.
I did say Master Blaster,
which, uh, was the original name for Master Chief.
They wanted to call him Master Blaster.
Uh, and the micro,
Bill Gates said, no,
Mr. Microsoft. I'm riffing,
and I can do that all day long because I have to.
That's what you do when you're a podcast host.
And, uh, yeah,
I'm riffing because I have to.
They have, they have me,
they make me say all this stuff.
Things that you don't want me to say,
they make me say them, such as,
a lot of our content is locked behind our Patreon.
They're making me say that.
I don't want to do it that way,
but they're making me say it.
So I want you guys to know.
give us money. Right.
If you want the, if you want access to those sweet additional episodes of Nostalgia,
known as Nostalgia Bites,
where we play the Famicom library,
you'll, might be intrigued to know,
the next game we're going to play is a game called Dig Dug.
That's right. The arcade game.
Now you're checking your notes right now.
You're like, I'm sure that Dig Dug was an NES game.
It wasn't. Never came out on the NES.
So we have to play it.
And the only way we know how,
which is on the Famicom with some Japanese,
but don't worry.
You don't need to know any Japanese.
We don't need to know any Japanese.
The Nostalgia Bites,
the hook of the whole show is that you don't need to know any Japanese to play these Japanese games.
A little strange, a little weird.
Japanese, Japanese. I'm saying it all left and right.
I like sushi.
That's not the point.
We're going to keep recording episodes with or without Nostalgia Bites next week.
Hollywood Squares.
No, we're not going to be on it.
We're going to be playing the NES game version of Hollywood Squares,
where who knows?
We'll do something fun. We did something fun for Jeopardy.
We didn't do anything fun for Wheel of Fortune.
So we kind of owe it up to ourselves and you guys to do something fun for Hollywood Squares.
No one made me say that.
That's really suspicious,
actually, now that you had to clarify.
Oh, Joe, I'm done,
by the way. Okay.
I'm going home.
Bye. Thank you.